hagamos algunos problemas de
desigualdades compuestas y estos son
problemas de desigualdades que tienen
más de un conjunto de restricciones ya
verás de qué estoy hablando en un
segundo así que vamos directamente a un
ejemplo y así que el primer problema que
tengo es menos 5 es menor o igual que x
menos 4 que es menor o igual que 13 y
aquí claramente se ve donde están las
dos restricciones que tenemos por un
lado menos 5 debe ser menor o igual que
x menos 4 y por el otro lado x 4 debe
ser menor o igual que 13 así que esto
nos da dos restricciones que debe
satisfacer esta equis y lo más sencillo
que podemos hacer en este momento es
separar esta de esta desigualdad en dos
por un lado vamos a tener que menos 5 es
menor o igual que x menos 4 y al mismo
tiempo y al mismo tiempo se debe
satisfacer que x menos 4 sea menor o
igual que 13 así que es
dos desigualdades se deben cumplir al
mismo tiempo así que esencialmente si lo
quieres ver como conjuntos
estamos interceptándola la solución de
este con la solución de esta otra así
que vamos a resolver por separado ok y
ya después vamos a recordar que tenemos
aquí una palabra muy importante que es
la conjunción y muy bien entonces
resolvamos esta primero para ir
despejando la equis pues podemos sumar
de ambos lados 4 sumamos 4 de ambos
lados y aquí me queda 9 perdón 9 es
menos 5 4 es menos 1 es menor o igual
que x menos 44 estos se cancelan y me
queda x así que x es mayor o igual que
menos 1 o si lo quieren ver de esta
forma x es mayor o igual que menos 1
aquí nos dice menos 1 menor o igual que
x estas dos son equivalentes realmente
verdad muy bien entonces esto es por un
lado por el otro que es lo que tenemos
que x menos 4 es menor o igual que 13 9
puedo sumar cuatro de ambos lados así
que del lado izquierdo esto se cancelan
y me queda que x es menor o igual que 13
más 4 que son 17 17 muy bien sí y hay
que recordar que tenemos la palabra y
esto quiere decir que se deben cumplir
ambos entonces esto lo podemos ya
reescribir digamos incluso como una como
una desigualdad compuesta como que menos
1 es menor o igual que x pero esa misma
x debe ser menor o igual debe ser menor
o igual que 17 muy bien entonces cómo se
vería el conjunto solución ya de estas
dos desigualdades digamos conjuntas
en línea muy grande digamos que por aquí
anda el 17 por acan del 18 quien sabe
que hay aquí en medio pero aquí está el
0 aquí en el -1 el menos 2 ok y bueno
por supuesto entre 0 y 17 hay muchas
otras cosas pero bueno con eso me basta
para ejemplificar esto lo primero que
podemos hacer es ver que x debe ser
mayor o igual que menos 1 entonces sí
puede ser menos 1 y nos tomamos todos
los que están a la derecha
pero no puede ser tan grande
ahora si no puede ser tan grande porque
también me dice que x debe ser menor o
igual que 17 ok entonces aquí están
todos los que están por arriba de menos
1 pero que también están por abajo de 17
así que este segmento es nuestro
conjunto solución y si quisiéramos
expresar lo en términos de intervalos
pues en realidad vamos de menos 1 a 17 y
ponemos esto este estos corchetes ya que
si estamos incluyendo menos 1 y también
estamos incluyendo a 17 entonces ya
tienes una buena noción de qué son los
problemas es decir de desigualdades
compuestas vamos a hacer otro ejemplo
vamos a hacer otro ejemplo y vamos a
hacer un poquito más más difícil pero es
la misma idea que hemos estado haciendo
el problema dice que menos 12 es menor
que 2 menos 5 x que es menor o igual que
7 entonces lo primero que puedes notar
es que aquí hay un menor y aquí hay un
menor o igual eso va a dar soluciones
un poco distintas cada vez que
resolvamos este tipo de problemas pero
la idea es esencialmente igual podemos
tomarnos esta primera desigualdad y
podemos resolver por aparte esta otra
morada muy bien entonces lo que tenemos
es que menos 12 es menor que 2 menos 5 x
y también tenemos otra desigualdad
tenemos la desigualdad morada que se
debe satisfacer al mismo tiempo que la
verde la morada nos dice que 2 menos 5 x
es menor o igual que 7 entonces estas
dos desigualdades se deben cumplir al
mismo tiempo y lo que vamos a hacer es
resolverlas por separado y ver cómo es
el conjunto solución de ambos muy bien
entonces para ir despejando la equis lo
primero que uno puede hacer es restar
dos de ambos lados restamos dos de ambos
lados y que es lo que me queda menos 12
menos 2 es menos 14 esto es menor que
estos se cancelan y me queda menos 5 x
muy bien entonces ahora para despejar la
x lo que podemos hacer es dividir todo
entre menos 5 pero pero hay que tener
mucho cuidado porque estaríamos
dividiendo entre un número negativo y ya
sabemos que si multiplicamos o dividimos
por un número negativo la desigualdad se
invierte cambia de sentido
entonces si dividimos entre menos 5
tendremos menos 14 entre menos 5 y aquí
tendremos simplemente equis verdad menos
5 x entre menos 5 pues es x
y la desigualdad ya no es un menor que
ahora va a ser un mayor que y entonces
menos 14 entre menos 5 es mayor que x
quién es esto esto por ejemplo expresado
en términos de fracción el número
compuesto es decir un número con una
fracción estos son dos enteros cuatro
quintos y es positivo porque tenemos
menos entre menos que es más entonces
dos enteros cuatro quintos es mayor que
equis esta es mi primera solución ahora
vamos a ver qué pasa del lado derecho
aquí nuevamente podemos restar dos de
ambos lados de hecho podríamos restar
dos en conjunto es decir hacerlos
simultáneos sin embargo puede esto
llegar a confundir y no es bueno para
nadie que nos confundamos así que yo te
sugiero que siempre separes 1º la
desigualdad en dos distintas
de aquí obtenemos que menos 5x verdad
restamos 2 justo para cancelar esto
menos 5 x es menor o igual que 7 menos
25 si dividimos todo entre menos 5 aquí
vamos a tener equis y 5 entre menos 5 es
menos 1 pero otra vez dividimos entre un
número negativo por lo tanto la
desigualdad se invierte y en vez de ser
un menor o igual se vuelve un mayor o
igual así que ya tenemos nuestras dos
soluciones x debe ser mayor o igual que
menos 1 y el mismo tiempo al mismo
tiempo debe ser más chico que 2 enteros
cuatro quintos entonces si lo ponemos en
términos de un de un este es un
intervalo lo que tenemos es que va de
menos 1 a 24 quintos donde el menos 1 si
lo estamos incluyendo pero el 2 entre
los cuatro quintos no esto es
estrictamente mayor no puede ser igual
así que en términos de intervalo así se
expresaría o bien
es menor o igual que x que es menor
que de hecho es menor estricto es menor
estricto que dos enteros cuatro quintos
muy bien
4 perfecto entonces estas dos cosas son
equivalentes vamos a ver cómo se vería
en la recta numérica
aquí tenemos nuestra recta por ejemplo
que aquí anda anda -1 y por acá está el
dos enteros cuatro quintos por supuesto
aquí han del 0 el 1 en fin pero bueno
con estas dos cosas me basta me dice que
x es mayor o igual que menos 1 donde si
puede ser menos 1 y nos tomamos todos
estos todos estos hasta llegar al 2
enteros cuatro quintos pero éste no
puede ser ese no puede ser no lo estamos
incluyendo así que así es como se
gráfica mi conjunto solución y bueno
estos son problemas que han sido
utilizando la conjunción y hagamos ahora
un ejemplo en donde usemos la palabra la
conjunción o digamos que tenemos el
conjunto de desigualdades 4x menos 1 es
mayor o igual que 7 y aquí vamos a
utilizar la palabra o o que se cumple
que 9 x sobre 2
es menor que 3 entonces estas
desigualdades deben ser o es decir la x
si es válida si satisface esta
desigualdad o si satisface esta
desigualdad o si satisface ambas pues
podría llegar a suceder entonces vamos a
ver cuál es el conjunto solución es
esencialmente lo que tenemos que hacer
es resolver cada una de estas y él
va a decir que vamos a unir las
soluciones muy bien entonces para ir
despejando x podemos sumar 1
uno de ambos lados y entonces que me
queda aquí que 4x es mayor o igual que
siete más uno que es ocho de donde si
pasamos el 4 dividiendo x es mayor o
igual que 2 verdad es decir dividimos
entre 4 de ambos lados y aquí se cancela
y 8 entre 4 es 2 y no tenemos que
cambiar el signo de la desigualdad
porque es positivo que entonces tenemos
que x es mayor o igual que 2 muy bien
por y esto o más bien se debe cumplir
eso o que 9 x entre 2 es menor que 3
podemos multiplicar por dos novenos de
ambos lados
por dos novenos de ambos lados aquí por
supuesto que el 2 se cancela con este el
9 con este y lo que me queda del lado
izquierdo es que x es menor que 3 por 2
sobre 9 si cancelamos aquí este 3 con un
3 del 9 me queda que x que x es menor
que dos tercios muy bien entonces x es
menor que dos tercios y el mir de ohl se
debe más bien es x es menor que dos
tercios y es mayor que mayor o igual que
2 muy bien entonces vamos a ver cómo se
ve esto yo sé que puede llegar a ser
confuso a veces
pero ya cuando lo graphic hemos va a ser
mucho más claro por ejemplo si aquí
tenemos el 0 y el 1
aquí anda el 2 y acaba el 3 en fin aquí
ya lo mejorando el menos 1 qué sé yo
entonces nuestro nuestra solución de la
primera es nos tomamos el 2 lo incluimos
y a partir de ahí nos vamos hacia la
derecha muy bien y de la otra solución
tenemos que x es menor que dos tercios
que x es menor que dos tercios que aquí
anda el dos tercios no lo incluimos y
nos vamos todo hacia la izquierda
entonces como realmente me está diciendo
que la x es mayor o igual que 2 o x es
menor que dos tercios en realidad estos
dos conjuntos forman toda la toda la
solución muy bien ya sea que estemos de
este lado o de este otro lado es válido
y eso es bastante interesante porque en
cualquiera en cualquiera de estos
conjuntos tenemos solución verdad en en
el rojo o en el verde si hubiéramos
utilizado la palabra y en lugar de o
no tendríamos solución verdad no puede
ser mayor o igual que 2 y al mismo
tiempo menor que dos tercios son son
ajenos estos conjuntos así que la única
razón por la que hay solución es porque
usamos la palabra o para cual para
cumplir cualquiera de estos cualquiera
de estas dos condiciones así que espero
que te haya resultado esto bastante
divertido